[Music]
hello my name is Gillian calico I'm a
national master from the state of
Missouri and today this is a
continuation of last week's lecture on
the four night Spanish starting with E 4
E 5 Knight f3 knight c6
Knight of six ninety three ninety six in
this eventual position which should be
fine now we'll be taking a look at some
actual games hopefully analyzing some
interesting variations but this this I
just want to say this variation is
mostly played to avoid certain move
orders so most people like playing the
Royal Oh pets with knight c6 played here
oops
and and then they're very happy once
they get here and sometimes their
opponents play Knight f6 and they're
unhappy because they don't want to play
the Berlin after castles 94 d4 96 Bishop
c6 d c d e an out of five queen d8 king
da and this position is very theoretical
lots of high-level games here black is
shown is shown to be doing just fine
now white white thinks to himself well
how do i how do I avoid this and one of
the possibilities although admittedly
not one of the more critical
possibilities is to just play Knight to
c3 which is the starting the starting
position of our tabia and also a move
order the white might one I'm sorry an
opening that white might want to avoid
is the Petroff or Russian game after
night of sex and seal play Knight c3 96
and then Bishop e5 and we once again get
into our tabia now this is a game
between John Donne famous British
Grandmaster and James Howell not to be
confused with David Howell James how it
was a very strong player from England
but not quite as strong as David Howe
I don't think there's any relation what
so the game continues Bishop before
castles castles d3d six Bishop g5 this
is the variation we saw last week to me
this is a little surprising that it's
been seen in so many high-level games
just because black gives up the bishop
pair on c3 for basically nothing I'm
waist forcing black to take on c3
basically Oh what would the audience do
here with the black pieces other than
Bishop c3 yeah 97 is is another
variation we'll look at a game here
later but why why might black want to
play Bishop c3 here what is white
threatening yeah that's correct and also
it can be shown here that Y can even do
it in the reverse order by playing
Bishop f6 you have to play G takes
because of Queen f6 and 95 if the Queen
moves away then you removed the defender
and you take on before with a winning
position so that's why black usually
plays Bishop takes c3 here although 97
is as I discussed last week probably a
better a better try for equality but
Bishop c3 was played BC Queen e7 so
basically everybody the that's played ie
45 with black was taught to play 98 96 I
was taught this several strong players
that I've talked to they were just told
yeah Black is fine if he just plays
Knight da 96 and has full equality I
have a two very strong friends they both
they both confirmed that's that's what
they were taught but this is actually
very incorrect because white just plays
rook e1 defending the e4 pawn 98 d4 and
white has the center and two bishops so
I lost the class what what should white
do
after 96 how would you play to maintain
your advantage
yes sorry
do you take c5 no I believe the problem
with D takes d5 is I will take back on
e5 and what's your idea after I just
take back because these pawns are not so
good anymore yeah now you might think
that you can just take on e5 but
unfortunately your Bishop on g5 is
sitting so you have some tactical
problems but otherwise yet this would be
a very good idea it just unfortunately
doesn't work in this precise moment so
you do need to save your bishop because
black just black just attacked it and by
the way against other random legal moves
like if white plates c4 here then black
is perfectly fine after 98 let's say c3
trying to maybe put the bishop back on
c2 96
yeah already here black is probably four
choice just because he has very good
darks core control and potential
potentially he's going to have very good
control over the f4 square so it's in
this precise move order that white has
an advantage because after ninety six
white has two very good responses
everybody at home already knows but
there's lots of new faces here so maybe
you can find it find the best move in
this position it's a funny one
the real question here is where do you
want to put your Bishop Wright which
diagonal like if you want to go to h4 or
anywhere else on the c12 h6 diagonal and
why where's the best square yes oh the
highest rated player is right Bishop
Bishop c1 bishop c1 is correct now the
problem with Bishop h4 is it really
linked wishes control over the f4 square
so the the knight possibly can jump
there at any time even now and overall
it loses a lot of control over this
diagonal and it doesn't really have a
future it's kind of just stuck doing its
one job on the h4 d a diagonal where
it's not that useful because you don't
really want to trade off for the night
because if you do like if you were to
play Bishop f6 here then black would be
clearly better because white has no
compensation for his destroyed structure
right he doesn't have the Bishop Harry
anymore so he's just worse and on h4 it
doesn't really have it has to pot
there's two things that could possibly
happen to it either it's going to trade
itself off for the knight on f6 or
eventually it's going to be kicked back
to g3 or it's just stuck in bed so
that's why h4 is bad now the other two
squares on this diagonal because f4 is
out of the possible I mean it's not even
an option right I take the bishop so
we're just there's three squares III d2
and c1 and why we pick C 1 over e 3 and
E 2
well on e 3 there's a problem what's the
problem
94 yes that's correct 94 so the points
hanging on you for right so Bishop III
is not possible why is Bishop d2 maybe
not the best yes I'm sorry
well there's nothing concrete but the
bishop blocks the view of the Queen so
the Queen doesn't see as much and the
bishop really isn't better on d2 than c1
but it makes all the other pieces and
White's position worse the knight on D -
all right then I don't have three no
longer has the D 2 square and I mean
white overall has less control over the
D file so Bishop c1 is the best move c5
and once again I'll ask what is the best
move for white very similar theme to
Bishop c1 a move to bend Feingold would
approve of Claudia readiness yeah that's
correct
Bishop f1 is correct Bishop c4 the
problem with Bishop c4 is once again you
don't want to trade off your bishop for
the night because then you have no
compensation for the damaged structure
right and the bishop on c4 is probably
going to get hit later by a six and B
five so it's a target and also what is
the bishop actually doing on aa c4 right
like it's not it's not really on a good
diagonal because there's so many things
in front and like it's not really active
yeah it's not doing anything it may as
well be on f1 where it's out of the way
of everything and it's not like exposed
and the bishop on c4 is not protected
right which is I mean might not be
important now but it could be later I
mean I'm always scared so Bishop Bishop
f1 is the best move
can somebody tell me why maybe this move
would be potentially bad
so it takes and white way it takes only
five so black black has a tactic here
that's correct
attacking the bishop which is exposed on
b5 and the knight on e5 so once again
what that's another reason to burn the
bishop back to f1 it's just out of the
way maybe in some variations I can take
on anything
rook dietas plate now obviously if I
take on e5 I can't take back because my
queen saying yeah
so Brooke D it's a good move it prevents
d5 g3
g3 is played why do you why do you think
g3 is played what might be the reason
yes yes potentially you could be stopped
being back ranked checkmates in the
future but anything else like anything
else that it does because h3 also so why
would g3 be preferable over the move h3
yes
the bishop has a lot of scope along this
diagonal it doesn't have a lot of scope
here so the bishops actually misplaced
on g2 so the it doesn't really help the
bishop get to a better diagonal or a
better square but it does do something
to one of your opponent's pieces
yes
that's correct so you also kind of kill
the play of your opponents night by
preventing it from ever going to f4 so
this move is restricting your opponent's
pieces so next move was 97 a black is
basically just shuffling here maybe
maybe blacks thinking about playing b5
that's why a 4 is played but overall
he's just kind of sitting back and
waiting for white to do whatever he's
gonna do this is the kind of position I
really don't like playing with the black
pieces I really like having white here
because I'm fine white I'm dictating the
play here and black just kind of has to
react which is why white is slightly
better actually more than slightly but
Bishop g4 is played d5 now it might be
weird to close the center when you when
you have the two bishops but on the
other hand potentially the knight could
be coming to the c-4 square where it
would be very it would be very nice and
you have more space so you're kind of
hoping to achieve the pawn break f2 to
f4 when that eventually happens the
position will open and your two bishops
will become monsters so rook goes to f8
why does black play wreck of a
what is blacks idea potentially
is he just moving back and forth you
know no plan yeah so what you so if if
you move your knight you want to put
pressure on this night right and how
does this move help that you're onto
something
actually there is an idea here so black
so when there's the structure right this
defined structure where because you want
to look where the pawn chain is pointing
right to see where you're playing
White's pawn changes pointed in this
direction so he's playing on the Queen
side in theory of course he's also he
has more space so he has more leeway
where he's playing but black's pawn
chain is i mean look at the pollen c5
usually in Kings any instruction 7 but
the pawn chain is pointing this way so
blacks gonna play on the Kings side so
the pawn break you want to achieve is f7
to f5 and the rook on f8 helps support
this brink so that's why Rick if a
displayed white recognizes the potential
danger and tries to kick the bishop away
immediately
the bishop goes away to d7 Bishop c8 is
also very interesting giving the d7
squared to the night
Bishop h5 is a mistake for the same
reason Bishop h4 was a mistake because I
just eventually the bishop gets trapped
on the g6 square so Bishop d7 Knight h4
going for the f5 square potentially also
trying to achieve this break f4 and last
week in the game between Karpov sorry
it's fiddler and carp off the knight
rerouted itself to g2 and it was very
powerful they're going to e3 supporting
maybe a Bishop c4 later here is not so
important because this diagonal isn't
open but f5 could be
could be a good point too it's a
pinpoint 98 it's also preventing black
from plaintiff 5c for preventing an eb-5
potentially g6 black of course is trying
to play for f5 with Knight g7 so I've
force played f6 now it's in this moment
that you have to kind of choose what do
you want to do with the white pieces
what type of game do you want to play
how would you proceed with the in the
current position if you were playing
this with white and so where do you want
your pieces well the first question I
want to ask you is which structure do
you want to play like what kind of
position do you want to take on e5 do
you want to leave the pawns where they
are do you want to play f5 because
there's some tension here you can you
can either resolve it or you can leave
it up to you but where do you want your
pieces you said you wanted to bring this
rock where
yeah it would be very nice to bring like
the rooks over to the Kings side right
there's something along those lines
but how like if that's what you want to
do which structure do you want to play
like what type of positions yeah because
you have a choice you can take on e5 you
can play a five you can leave it so if
you burn your rook rook in right now
right it's not gonna do a lot because
the G file isn't like even close to
being open right and there's nothing
really to attack black doesn't have like
a clear weakness
why does clear weaknesses right like the
C 4 and C C 2 and C 3 everything on the
C file could potentially be weak but
black black does not have anything in
his position that would be classically
weak he just has less space so how would
you proceed
Claudio so the problem with these plans
I think is well first of all if you
bring your rook over this way right you
have to deal with this problem somehow
all right the other rook so Bishop d3
this pawn is hanging right but if you if
you play keen h2 and Bishop d3 and put
your rook here or something that's that
that could be an idea right but what do
you do after that
so let's say I give you I give you all
this right so keen h2 Bishop d3 rack f1
how do you proceed what's your next step
I mean let's pretend black just passes
you're already in that position I I
don't know I don't know if it I don't
know if it helps maybe it does but I
don't I don't see how it helps I think I
think that um basically why it wants to
define the structure now or I mean you
could do it later but you should you
should play what was played in the game
which is f5 and because now you you're
making sure that black commits to to
play in g5 this tension isn't good for
him if he weakens it like you have v
square and this piece is coming in but
now I can tell you what what White's
plan should be right now that the
structures defined White's plan should
definitely be to play h4 and then crash
through on the H file right so now
there's a definite plan that Y can try
to employ so 97 H for H 693 so the night
is now improved now then the night is on
its ideal square right it's controlling
the f5 square the g4 square it can the
night has no better score on the board
you can't think of one legally I mean II
six would be nice but unfortunately we
can't have everything in life yeah so
keen f7 is played it should be to
ricochet so white is preparing to I mean
these moves are all played just to put
the rooks on the h-file Queen B 5 is
just provoking the opponent rook rook to
h1 so why does achieved everything now
it's time to convert you put your knight
on g4 attacking h6 97 takes takes rook
takes rook takes and it is white to play
and win
and if I play so keen ha9 f7 obviously
right okay but if I play kena kena fate
because okay nine age six teenage eight
knight of seven King GA 98 right so
that's that's pretty obvious but what
happens if black goes to FA you I mean
you can't just like I mean maybe it's
nothing maybe it's it's possible
you know right
yeah yeah of course yeah yeah yeah all
right so Claudio reveals all 1986 Tina
Fey Knight f7 attacking the Queen and
the rook anyway so it doesn't matter
that the Knights didn't go to f7 was
check because the Queen on d8 is on
priests kenaf seven rook h7 and the game
is basically over white white is
infiltrated on the H file and he's
collected a lot of material way it
wrapped up the game quite nicely with
just rook aged six Queen takes and
eventually black just resigned because
white princess kina he's going here and
here and yeah I mean but White has more
rugs by the way a potential so let's say
Bishop d7
well Bishop d7 a five might just be
immediate so like black might already
just beans legs on but there's a funny
plan so like even if like this happens
say Bishop d7 can play Bishop g5 here
takes an f6 and then you take this is
good for white because not only does he
have more works but he has more Queens
anyway so what to take away from this
game I I would not play this position
with black in the opening
I've given two examples one in this
class and two overall and in the four
Knights Spanish on why this position
specifically should be good for white
with bishops you wanted Bishop f1 I
think White has two bishops very easy
play he I mean strategically it's very
nice you you just stop all blacks
counter play on the Queen side and then
eventually you just play on the Kings
side with that for maybe Knight G to you
eventually prepare it in this in this
example it was very simple white just
played off five and after g5 now this is
a strategically winning position
eventually white will just crash through
on the Kings side with h4 this is not a
long-term defense for black he's just
kind of hoping the you
as his opponent might not find the right
plan so this position is just I I think
this is just winning fur for white here
the rest of the game I mean it was
pretty natural
oh yeah yeah but you're not in time
right nine ninety-two night yeah by the
way what Claudia mentioned this is how
you usually respond so like let's say
you pass for okay three or something
then H five and you respond to h4 with
g4 and by the way these positions are
always very unpleasant because like why
it might be able to sack like if you
because why does an infinite time he can
put his pieces wherever he wants he can
put his keen on a1 he can put both of
his rooks on the kingside and then he'll
take on g4 and then the game might just
end right but he that's like a dream
scenario for black because here you're
not even in time white just goes h4 and
after h5 you just take on g5 and you
have a passed pawn on f5 event
eventually you should break through so
anyway let's continue with the with the
next game a game that I really want to
talk about which is where is this game
is it yeah it's way e versus rod Raja
Tina Roger time a train okay so we get
to our starting position way you plays
the Royal Pez rushing plays the night of
the night of six the Berlin and ye
avoids it with nice III a fan-favorite
at home by the way night DeForest played
so this is like the critical line
hopefully I'll come back to Bishop
before if we have time I don't I don't
know this game is pretty complicated and
I definitely want to show this one so 94
you can't take on e5 obviously because
you take on b5 and play Queen e7 I show
that last week Bishop a4 the other
variation was Bishop c4 but this is the
more interesting one Bishop a4 c6 95 D 5
D 356 F 4 this is basic sorry this is a
the beginning to a starting position
that is very rich a lot of tactics can
occur both sides are playing for their
goals this is like this is why we play
chess like this is a
all of ideas material versus activity
Bishop c5 e takes d5 castles D takes c6
it's not necessary for black to waste
time with a Knight takes d5 probably
that just lets white white get out with
like 94 and then see a possible c3 later
so black just castles and let's white
take all these pawns but I mean black is
fully developed and look at White's King
he's not castling this way that's for
sure
I mean all of blacks key pieces are
there and yeah black takes back on c6
white needs to solve his problem right
white needs to develop his pieces and he
needs to put his cane in a safe position
now ordinarily I mean I would never I
would try to never show this game to
beginners right because they might try
to do something silly and and in their
own tournament games but here after
sorry HD is the best move rook e8
the way white solves this problem
because you don't want to go towards the
Kings side you want to go towards the
Queen side but you just don't have time
to prepare castles Queen side so the way
you solve that problem is by playing
Queen d2 97 and Kim D 1 which is very
unusual you don't don't try this at home
I mean get to this position try it but
don't do this like under normal
circumstances why does this work here
white is giving up his material
advantage in order to complete
development because white doesn't just
have material advantages he has
positional advantages if you look at the
structure white has a perfect posture
right this is one pawn island right this
is one pawn island and this is another
pawn island the pawns on f4 g2 and h4
I mean h3 black on the other hand has
split pawns on a 7 and c6 and ok the
pawns on f7 g 7h 7 are perfect pawn
island but if if white gets to some
ending where it's equal material then he
can press forever so he wants to give up
whatever material advantage he has now
to play for something more 10
like something safer later so 95 takes
so whites trading pieces because he's
getting attacked rookie five now what
would you play here with white you need
to trade off some material because
otherwise you're just going to get made
it how do you how do you manage to trade
off some of blacks attackers yeah
actually this would be very nice so if
the night goes to e4 Mouse kills not
there
if none goes to e4 it would be very nice
to trade off the night for the bishop in
fact that would be just winning for you
because you would have two bishops and I
mean blacks attack is dead without the
dark square Bishop black would just move
but unfortunately black would just move
this Bishop away right and
yeah this is actually correctly you
should play Ricky one here and 94 is a
potential as always as always a move to
consider but Rick you want is stronger
here because it actually forces the
immediate rate of the Brooks I mean
unless you're putting your hook on h5
which is a very silly square and then
white will proceed with 94 as mentioned
followed by C 3 and d 4 white is just
clearly better yeah if you move your
queen to back up the Berkshire and we
still trader trader drugs right so white
still achieve this goal I think the
problem with doing that specifically is
that is that if you if you put your
Queen on e5 then once my knight moves
I'm not sure probably even this month 92
30 need another trade your queen is is
gonna be a target for I mean more trade
trading threats with like Queen up four
or something a c3 d4 might come with
tempo instead black just trades on e1
Queen goes to e1 and Bishop f5 is played
okay now this is a key move if Y I mean
white I think I think this is forced
if you don't play this move with white
you're much worse if like not lost
because blacks activity is so powerful
although blacks position is a little
Pocari yeah but where would you put your
bishop
f4 f4 f4 is a good square but
unfortunately I think after Bishop f4 so
problem with this move in general like
in chess queen pawn opening is this pawn
this pawn is like exposed
I think this move is strong I'm not sure
but I think Queen b6 is strong targeting
b2 and if you protect this somehow
then I I'll move my knight to attack
your bishop
so like King see 196 this is just a
variation off the top of my head
if you move your Bishop away this way
right covering the e3 Square from my
bishop then black has rook b8 attacking
b b2 you might be able to cover with
Bishop b3 and then like a five maybe
fall by I know sorry probably here a
bishop of - I think this position like
blacks activity compensates him enough
for his material different deficit if
not more more so I mean I would rather
be black
that's correct why 25 yeah you you you
have your eyes on both bishops this one
is immediately hanging and the in it I
mean and it's just keeping an eye on the
bishop on our five the best move is
Bishop b6 and this position is
objectively equal you can look this up
home but black actually played a move
which loses surprisingly and it's a very
natural move it's Queen of fate blacks a
very strong player rated like 2680 of
course way at the time was only 25 50
but nowadays he's like top 15 in the
world so he's no slouch
what did way you play here with the
white pieces so if you were to play
Bishop III I believe that rook e8 is
strong before
so I believe the rookie three and night
see two wins although maybe there's
something stronger you know your your
queen is hanging and your records hang
is there something stronger see I think
I mean I don't see why that isn't good
enough probably that's just good enough
right
yeahjust rookie 3 and 92 ones so instead
I mean black is black had a point with
Queen f8 like Queen of fates not like a
stupid move it's just it's not it's not
obvious unless you know that it's
obvious White has a tactic here actually
that's correct because you're removing
that I mean the the Knights overloaded
right it's protecting the pollen c6 on
the bishop on a5
so 96 we have 594 knife goes back to d4
and white white actually already has a
winning position here because blacks
attack has kind of died down and he has
a lot of material for seemingly not a
lot Queen f4 rook e8 Bishop d2 the Queen
moved to e7 and I will offer anybody way
you did not find like the most precise
move here but White has a very very
strong move here which leads to
basically a winning position
in the game he played Quinn g5 offering
yet another trade keeping to the theme
of this game
so I think everybody in this class would
agree that the real Kanye one doesn't do
a lot right and you kind of want to make
space for your pieces over on the side
of the board because that's that's where
they're gonna live like the Keynes not
going that way right
the king has to go this way and it's not
safe right now but if the your King gets
to safety then what are you like two
healthy pawns up so you would just have
a winning position
94 and c3 is not the you have something
a little bit more immediate but 94 and
c3 is also a potentially good plan I
think I think the problem is there's yes
that's correct yes that's correct
so B for attacking the bishop and now
now when the bishop moves you can
protect your pawn
obviously you can't take the pawn on b4
because the knight is hanging on
once you protect your your pawn on
before you can move the King to beat it
is there questioning her okay all right
so anyway queen chief I was playing in
the game threatening a Queen trade Queen
b7 attack attacking b2 and maybe black
realised his mistake and now he's
preventing pawn to b4 well I mean funny
before was played anyway but it's not as
good now as it was in this position
before Bishop goes back to b6 taking
taking with the bishop allows rook to be
one where white a white gives up a pawn
for activity right but black didn't want
black I'm sorry black didn't want white
to have any activity he just wanted to
play with the compensation so it just
should be six Queen before at rook e1 is
the same like white is plain like he's
giving up material to get some
development back so Bishop e6 Queen d5
Queen c7 kin c1 and the King goes to B -
so will you eventually found the right
plan although
a little bit a little bit late Quincy
for Quincy three can be to Quincy 294 so
the night goes to e4 obviously to
protect the bishop but it also does
something else
so after queen h3 Iowa once again asked
what tactic there's a tactic here for
white it's white to play and regain his
advantage
Claudia already knows
yeah Claudia no I'll give I'll give the
rest of the class maybe 20 seconds do
you know 95 is the correct theme but
it's incorrect here because if you just
plain ng 5 I move my Queen to h5 or f5
defending f7 but you are on the right
track
notice that the g5 square connects the
f7 and the h3 square
that's why it's yes
mm-hmm so after 96 what happens if I
play correct e6 and if I play Queen c8
you know occasionally Queens can move
backwards they recently patch that into
the game I'm just kidding
that's correct Queen f7 often time and
often times and tactics if you see like
a move order and it doesn't work you can
reverse the move order and it does work
so like 95 didn't work because the Queen
just moves to protect f7 but Queen f7 is
a forcing move basically forcing black
to play tnow 795 and you get to this
ending where White has an extra pawn and
it's a very unbalanced ending where it's
4 4 on 1 & 2 on 0 why does an obvious
edge just because he's a pawn but I mean
this is far from the end Knight f3
Bishop f4 ship d4 c3 Bishop goes to f6
so black is just weakened White's entire
structure white plays Knight f2 attack
and start protecting the d3 pawn bishop
h4 we should III you can't just take on
f2 and take on d3 because that a sevens
hanging and as you might know in race
positions where there's pawns on both
sides actually I'll ask which piece
would you rather have a bishop or a
knight all right let's have a vote when
there's pawns on both sides and it's a
race who wants to have a knight raise
your hand
nobody raises their hands all right who
votes who votes for Buchanan's all right
all right
in general Bishop's are better when
there's pawns on both sides of the board
the Knights are better when the pawns
are on one side of the board because you
know the Knights of short-range peace so
it doesn't like a lot of damage right it
can go to both color complexes but
bishops and in this position black would
just be losing like Bishop f2 is a
horrible move and taking d3 because this
bishop sees these pawns from really far
away this night has to travel all the
way over here to stop this pawn that
takes a long time the bishop can do that
in one move the knight takes like a
thousand I mean three or four but
whatever actually how many squit and
it's five all right anyway anyway um
anyway so rookie rookie eight was played
so now if you take a seven
what would black do yes yes that's
correct and if you and if you move then
what happens continue at your line
yes that's correct and black just wins a
piece it's true that bishops are better
than this is also a very interesting
ending but black is the one on the
better side of it now having an extra
piece so anyway after Ricky a 94 was
played black plays the movement 91
winning winning the d3 pawn because
after rook da six the white is no good
way of protecting d3 a4 was played Y
doesn't really care about protecting his
pawn the thing that matters in these
race positions is time whoever has the
most time like if my pawns are on b7 and
a7 I went right or b8 in a even like
good but so black a white sacrifices his
pawn on d3 in exchange for like a little
bit of extra time in this race and
objectively he is winning rookie for b5
take take h5 bishop d4 is a very strong
move it cuts the rooks activity along
the fourth rank Bishop g5 b6 so white is
ahead in this race Bishop f4 rook f3
rook h3 is the best move and white is
winning but ok honestly what he did is
is more than finding a practical game
there's some crazy computer line here
that justifies why rook h3 is better
than Rick if rook go through but there
is a reason I believe work h3 g6 and the
point is that you're putting your rook
here which gives you like some
additional time but rook F 3 is is
strong because after g5 can concede to
kin D 3 what we'll discover is
oftentimes in the ending rooks are worse
at stopping passed pawns than bishops
why this this ending is better for white
I mean why does more time and he's
actually
queening with check so c6h to b7 Rock h3
was played here was the last moment
where where black could have survived
although he would be much worse after h1
equals Queen and then white would make a
queen after rook age 3 this is like
forced mate in 24 my way you did not
find it unfortunately I mean he
such a pastor who doesn't find mating 24
but or whatever whatever certain number
but he he found a very concrete way to
win anyway he just I mean you
when you have Queen when the Queen can
cover all the light squares the Bishop
covers all the dark squares you can find
making nuts
so here black Shekinah is so weak after
Queen h8 King g6 Queen f6 KH v queen of
four queen of five team went back to h6
they repeated a couple times you took
out four just to be safe and then he
eventually put his queen on e6 and just
played c7 because now that his Queens
know that his queens on f6 he can block
with Bishop c3 and well he's gonna have
a new queen on the board soon so Brooke
h4 Keane King to five Queen d1 king c5
quit g1 b5 and eventually he will get to
a safe square block with on e6 Queen b5
check Queen b6 King b8 and now you'll
see why the bishop on the wall diagonals
so useful stopping record shade there's
now no way to prevent see a queen I
would highly recommend this was a lot of
fun for me
just like personally analyzing this this
ending alone at home I would recommend
everybody to to analyze this ending this
isn't this is really fun but yeah
unfortunately I think that's all I have
time for tonight thank you very much
this was Julian pearl echo part two of
the four nights Spanish
[Music]